the fact that
shelling can damage a
nuclear power plant is certainly
not the reactor itself that is damaged as soon as possible, the
reactor is well
protected, it has a powerful body and the
concrete shell is still alive, the
reactor cooling system can be damaged, as a result of
which, in principle
, a
rather severe accident is possible, but not
at the level of Chernobyl  sims when
volatile radionuclides can also be released,
for example, I 131 communications 137 the
release of these radionuclides in the first
place if it is an operating
reactor or a recently operated reactor and
targets 137 which has a sufficiently long
half-life of 30 years
poses a serious danger to
people and in the quantities that it
such assessments can be thrown out,
then it is
only the lying
regions of Ukraine that suffer, the
population that lives there, but to a
lesser extent,
for example, from the Black Sea,
there are calculations showing that
residents of Bulgaria and the Roma can also suffer to a much lesser extent  ynia and
russia,
but we are not talking about the fact that this will lead
to a significant number of deaths,
but it
may be necessary to
resettle part of the territory, there may be
tens of kilometers from the village and
regular desimetric control on the
beaches of the black sea, but naturally along the
dnieper now and for years no one needs
this department  it makes sense to do
only if some kind of accident
really happens